a tiny gold bullet against the
coronavirus this precious pellet coated
in a new prototype vaccine has just
started trials in mice first results
show it works differently to other
vaccines already being tested in humans
yeah you can see big spots here each of
those is a really good t-cell responding
to the vaccine making the cytokine
that's basically going to kill that
virus it activates the immune systems
killer T cells that clear infections
from the body that means we've got a
very potent t-cell T cell that can kill
a virus very quickly
despite its promise the vaccine can't
get funding the government has put 100
million pounds into experimental
vaccines being developed in Oxford and
Imperial College London but 90% of
vaccines fail before they reach the
clinic it's a bet that may not pay off
and the other vaccines primarily work on
antibodies not t-cells it's an important
difference not only should you get
longer-lasting immunity but also this
one should work well in the elderly
precisely the people who need protection
the most you just hold that against the
arm and you just fire it into the
patient the same T cell technology has
been used to harness the body's defenses
to fight skin cancer even those with
advanced melanoma were far less likely
to relapse it gives scientists
confidence that it would work against
the corona virus trying to find a
vaccine against melanoma which is your
own body but slightly abnormal is a
harder ask than a completely foreign
invader so I think if it can do that for
melanoma
I think it's more likely to be able to
do it for a virus 10 experimental jabs
are already in clinical trials worldwide
like the nottingham vaccine they train
the immune system to attack the protein
spikes that the virus uses to get into
cells but that's the most likely part of
the virus to mutate which could make
them less effective so the Nottingham
vaccine has a backup priming the immune
system to target proteins inside the
virus
it's not only an insurance policy
against mutations those proteins are
common to other coronaviruses so it
could protect against the next pandemic
vaccine specialist warren is best to
spread your bets
majority of the vaccine candidates are
focusing on the spike protein as that is
the mechanism that we understand from
coronaviruses of our own to get into the
self that makes most sense to focus on
however having all our eggs in one
basket so to say may not you know and if
that isn't the best approach it'll be
good to have other options
keeping options open could be the
difference between stopping the pandemic
and not Thomas More Sky News Nottingham